[Gospel chorus singing.]
[Narrator:] I want you to meet Mrs. Mary Cooley, a midwife, who lives in Albany, Georgia.
[Mary is shown ironing.]
[Narrator:] This is a story of how she helps people,
people like Ida Fleming who engaged Miss Mary to deliver her third child.
People like Adam and Marybell Dudley, newcomers to Dougherty County who bring their troubles to this midwife.
In the county health department are doctors and nurses who help Miss Mary
do the job to which she and thousands of other midwives all over the south
have dedicated their lives: of birthing of healthy babies.
[Chorus singing.]
[Ida looks at wall filled with photos of infants and children.]
[Ida:] All these your babies, Miss Mary?
[Miss Mary:] Yes. They is all my babies.
Delivered about 1,400. [Inaudible] come this year.
[Ida:] Here's my two. I'm gonna send you a real little baby picture of this next one, Miss Mary.
[Miss Mary:] Well, you do that then, honey.
[Mary is packing her medical bag.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Miss Mary:] Lord, that Ida. Ain't nothing bothering her now, but I remember four years ago she was so scared.
I had to take her to the clinic myself.
Back in those days, our clinic was meeting at the old building.
[A white man and a white woman are at the front of the room, addressing several African-American midwives.]
[Miss Mary:] Dr. Andrew had been our health officer, for I guess just about a year.
[Miss Dixon:] Ida Fleming?
[Chorus singing.]
[Ida follows the nurse into an exam room.]
[Miss Mary:] Little Miss Dixon always try to help mommas feel easy the first time in the clinic.
Of course, I foretold Ida already what they going to do.
[Miss Dixon takes Ida's vital signs, smiling and speaking to Ida.]
[Miss Mary:] How they take each mother's temperature and feel their pulse.
Every time a mother comes to the clinic, they measure her blood pressure.
That's another way they can tell if she's keeping in good shape or, if she ain't,
the things she had better do to get herself well so she can have her baby more easy and normal.
[Laughter]
[Miss Mary:] Ida's doing just fine.
The first visit they draw off a little blood for a test and in eight months they do the same.
That's to see if the mother need to take the treatments.
Every time the mother comes to the clinic she brings along a little bottle of her water for a urine test.
That's to make sure that her kidneys is working all right.
When our patients begin their check-up early like Ida did,
then we midwives ain't so have to run up against something beyond our handling.
Dr. Newton examines all the mothers the first time they come into the clinic
and again in eight months and between times if they need it.
[Ida sits at the edge of the examining table and the doctor walks over to her.]
[Miss Mary:] When it come Ida's time for the doctor, she knowed already it wasn't nothing for her to be scared about.
[Ida and Miss Mary laughing]
[Ida:] I didn't know nothing when I first come to see you.
[Miss Mary:] Yes, honey, but you knows a-plenty now.
Come on over and let's look at your baby things.
[Chorus singing.]
[Mary and Ida walk over to Ida's home.]
[Miss Mary:] I always visit my mommas ahead of time if I possibly can get to it.
'course I knowed before I got here Aunt Mattie and Ida would have everything fixed up nice.
[Chorus singing.]
[Midwives, pregnant women, and their families are shown preparing for deliveries:
sterilizing items, folding and arranging bedding and cloths, and tending to older children.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Preparations continue for the birth of a new baby.]
[Midwives are seated in rows in a meeting room, talking amongst themselves.]
[A doctor is seated at the front of the room.]
[Midwife:] Mary late this morning.
[Midwives:] Yeah!
[Doctor:] Two days ago a baby delivered by a midwife died when it ought to have lived.
As your health officer, it was my duty to find out why that baby died.
My examination showed that its cord got infected and you all know what that means.
Something wasn't clean.
Maybe the midwife didn't boil her scissors long enough,
or it could have been that the dressing she used wasn't sterile,
or it might have been that she got in a hurry and didn't wash her hands well.
You midwives in this county have built up a wonderful reputation.
You work hard and I know how difficult it is to keep things clean in some of the homes where you have to go.
[Midwife:] That's right.
[Doctor:] But your record shows that you can keep clean and when something like this happens, it's a warning to all of us.
To us doctors, the nurses as well as to you midwives. It shows us how very easily we can slip back when we get careless.
[Midwives are seated around a table with a doll figure lying on it, practicing tying off the umbilical cord.]
[Miss Mary:] I've been doing the same thing about 18 years,
but I still know I can slip if I don't keep checking on myself.
These young girls who are just starting out,
they have an advantage because they are learning the right way at the beginning,
but you know old folks can change too if they just put their mind to it.
[Adam and Maybell arrive at Miss Mary's home to speak with her about delivering their baby.]
[Miss Mary:] You people seem to be new around here to me.
[Adam:] Yes'm.
[Miss Mary:] Well, how far are you along with this pregnancy, honey?
[Maybell:] About six or seven months, I think.
[Miss Mary:] What did the doctor say about your case, honey?
[Adam:] She ain't seen no doctor.
[Miss Mary:] Oh well, before I can take her case she'll have to see a doctor.
She'll have to take a blood test and go through an examination.
[Adam:] What's all that for?
[Miss Mary:] It's for the protection of her and also her baby.
How you know but what she don't need treatment?
Maybell, is this your first baby?
[Maybell:] No, it ain't.
[Miss Mary:] Well, just tell me, honey, how did you get along with all your pregnancies?
[Adam:] Our first one come dead. The next one dropped before she got far along with it.
[Miss Mary:] Well, you just got to see a doctor.
Maybell, I tell you what to do.
Come on down to the clinic Friday morning, hear?
[Adam:] That's not going to hurt you.
[Miss Mary:] 'Course not. It's not going to hurt you.
Y'all stop by at four now and I'll go with you.
[Adam:] Thank you, Miss Mary. I'll bring her by.
[Miss Mary:] All right.
Dr. Newton said Maybell ain't been eating right and it shows up on her.
[Maybell is lying on an exam table. Dr. Newton touches discolorations on her face.]
[Miss Mary:] He says every mother oughta have a good examination all over as soon as she thinks she's pregnant.
He said Maybell ought to have start getting her check-up months ago.
Poor Miss Penny, sure got a problem on her hands.
Yes, that was just my day for trouble.
Another lady there just begging to be my patient, but I most know she needed the doctor.
[The doctor, Miss Mary, and another woman sit together at a table in the clinic.]
[Miss Mary:] Dr. Newton said I was right about that thing and he showed me a danger sign.
The lady has been having sharp headaches all the time.
The doctor said being pregnant right by itself is no cause for a healthy woman to feel all dizzy and drug out.
[The doctor palpates the pregnant woman's lower leg and ankle.]
[Miss Mary:] The lady's ankle is all swelled up; that's another bad sign.
In the clinic, they keeps checking on three things:
the patient's weight, her blood pressure, and her urine.
This lady's clinic chart shows that she had been putting on too much weight,
especially in the last two months.
Her blood pressure had been going up likewise, way above what it ought to be.
When they tested her urine, it showed up cloudy, full of [inaudible] the doctor said.
Instead of water clear like a well mother's.
After Dr. Newton got through explaining all of that,
then the lady agreed herself it was better to let the doctor wait on her.
Now the nurse is always advising the patient on what to eat and how to take care of themselves.
[Miss Penny is speaking to Maybell and pointing out healthful foods, such as an egg, displayed on a table next to them.]
[Miss Mary:] Miss Penny, she keeps a sharp eye out for the puny patients like Maybell,
and if they eat what she say to eat, they mostly gets along okay.
[Chorus singing.]
[Maybell's husband plows and she is shown chopping wood in the yard of a home in poor condition.]
[Miss Mary:] [Now I just didn't know how Maybell was living out there, 11 miles down that [hard-up?] road.
[Maybell walks slowly toward the house and enters the kitchen where a pan of food is on the stove.]
[Miss Mary:] Looked like Maybell done forgot what Miss Penny told her to eat,
but you know it's hard to eat when you ain't hungry and by yourself all day long.
[Maybell walks through the interior of the house, which is sparsely furnished, with walls insulated with tacked-up paper. She checks her face in the mirror.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Miss Mary:] That place of hers was a regular mess out there.
I give her a box myself to start to collecting up her baby things,
but it look like Maybell ain't thinking about nothing such as that.
Still it's hard to know just what a person got on his mind sometime.
But taking a look at all the mothers that come to the clinic, them that have the trouble is very few.
[It is dark out, and Miss Mary walks up to Ida's house with Ida's husband, Tom.]
[Miss Mary:] Don't worry about that, Tom. Look like all my babies comes at night.
[Aunt Mattie:] Sure been looking out for you, Miss Mary.
[Miss Mary:] Took me a time to wake up, honey.
You said it coming pretty strong, Ida?
Well, we'll be getting ready right quick.
[Two toddlers are shown asleep in bed. Tom pulls the covers up around their shoulders.]
[Miss Mary:] I need a little more water to rinse off my hands, Aunt Mattie. That'll do fine.
Let me see now. Bed made fresh, linens for the bed's ready.
I wish to goodness all my mothers could have everything fixed up this nice.
I'll have to move the bed over to get under that light.
Baby tray fixed. Gonna move that table down this way to lay out my things on.
Even got the slop jar fixed on the paper.
Let's see how you're doing, Ida.
[Miss Mary approaches Ida, who sits in a highback chair.]
[Miss Mary:] You're fine, there ain't no hurry.
[Miss Mary continues to check her sterilized instruments and make her preparations.]
[Ida grimaces.]
[Miss Mary:] I'm watching the clock, honey.
[Humming]
You can walk around some if you want to.
I remember, Ida, when I was having my third baby.
[Laughter]
That little old hard-headed boy. He weighed about a...
Just relax yourself and don't think about nothing.
[Ida is in bed now.]
[Miss Mary:] I have known patients to drop right off to sleep between times,
and just sleep and sleep 'til the baby is almost here.
[Ida's eyes open; Aunt Mattie walks out of the room.]
[Miss Mary cleans her fingernails and scrubs her arms.]
[Scrubbing sound]
[Aunt Mattie thoroughly washes her hands, too.]
[Mary scrubs and the camera pans over to instruments, jars, and linens at the ready.]
[Miss Mary:] Bear to when you feel one coming, honey,
but pretty soon I want you to start pushing down and pant like a dog.
[Panting]
[Laughter]
[Miss Mary:] Remember now, that's to keep the baby's head from coming down too fast.
What you want this time, Ida, little girl or a boy?
[Ida:] It don't make no difference to me.
[Baby crying]
[Miss Mary:] Warm up the blanket good night, Mattie.
He'll be wanting it now as soon as I get the drops in his eyes.
[Baby crying]
[Miss Mary:] Hold still now you little scrawny rawny.
You'll soon be through.
[Ida:] Tell me, Momma, who do he favor?
[Aunt Mattie:] It's too early to tell yet a while, honey.
[Chorus singing.]
[Miss Mary:] Now, let's see if this youngun knows how to eat.
You remember what I told you last time, Ida, about nursing your baby right off?
That'll make your womb draw up and you won't lose so much blood.
Yes, smart little ole bugger.
He's catching on to the idea right quick.
Aunt Mattie, come help me get all my old dirty stuff tied up in my gown.
[Chorus singing.]
[Mary returns to her house and sits down on her bed.]
[Sigh]
[Miss Mary:] Just too wore out to fix a clean bag tonight.
I'll fix it early in the morning.
[Chorus singing.]
[Mary is dreaming.]
[Doctor in the dream:] What that means, something wasn't clean.
Something wasn't clean.
[Miss Mary:] Lord, just can't sleep with them thoughts preying on my mind.
[Mary gets out of bed and pulls items from her medical bag.]
[Maybell's husband Adam runs up and knocks furiously on the door.]
[Adam:] Miss Mary, Miss Mary, Miss Mary, wake up, Miss Mary. Miss Mary.
[Miss Mary:] Oh, go away, man. I've just now got into bed.
[Adam and Mary pull up to Adam and Maybell's house in an old truck and go inside.]
[Maybell is half on the floor, clutching a chair and crying.]
[Miss Mary:] Lord, Maybell, what you doing down on that floor?
[Adam:] Ain't the baby come yet?
[Miss Mary:] Oh, man, you hush and go bring me some wood here and some water!
Help with this fire.
I'm sure glad I brought some newspapers and some clean rags along with me, Maybell.
Maybell, I just can't deliver no baby on the floor now because it's too dangerous.
[Maybell:] Yes, Miss Mary.
[Miss Mary:] You'll find this a heap better anyway.
I'ma get my things all boiled up, Maybell,
and then we'll be ready.
[Mary boils her instruments over a fire in the fireplace.]
[Mary scrubs her hands and arms.]
[Miss Mary:] As ready as I can be with her coming along so fast.
Make a baby bed out that box; get some use out of it anyway.
Adam Dudley, come here quick! I need you!
I want you to go to the clinic and get me an incubator. Quick!
[Adam:] This one come dead too, Miss Mary?
[Miss Mary:] Dead? What do you think?
[Mary shows Adam his newborn baby.]
[Miss Mary:] Hurry now!
[Mary hums as she goes about her work. The new baby is in a makeshift bassinette with a hot water bottle under the covers and Maybell is in bed.]
[Miss Mary:] Maybell, now the most important thing for you to do is to keep the baby warm.
Don't handle him anymore than you just obliged to.
[Adam arrives at the clinic.]
[Adam:] Miss Penny, baby come too soon.
[Miss Mary:] Oh, Miss Penny, I'm glad you come.
[Miss Penny and Adam move an incubator into the house.]
[Miss Penny:] Let's put it at the foot of the bed, Adam, where it's out of the draft.
[Adam:] Yes, ma'am.
[Moving sounds]
[Miss Penny:] You've got to keep this full of hot water all the time to keep this baby warm.
[Adam:] Yes, ma'am. Then I better go cut some more wood.
[Unidentified female:] Now I'm goin' and fix Maybell something to eat.
[Miss Penny:] That's a good idea.
My, what a husky little peanut we have here.
There's nothing wrong with coffee and grits,
but a mother should have milk and vegetables and meat from the first day on
to be strong enough to take care of her little baby.
[Female:] I'll take care of him, Miss Penny. And see that she gets something.
[Chorus singing.]
[Miss Mary:] Daddy Adam, come on over here and put your name on your baby's birth certificate.
What you goin' call him, Adam Junior?
[Adam:] I reckon.
[Chorus singing.]
[Baby is shown with eyes closed, then stretching,]
[Maybell:] That baby's too little to live, ain't he?
[Adam:] Oh, Lord, honey.
[Maybell is crying.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Ida is lying in her bed smiling, with her toddler daughter next to her.]
[Miss Mary:] Next morning I go to see how Ida and her baby gettin' along.
Looks like everything is fine with Ida and, Lord, that baby.
A healthy little ole thing as you ever saw. Yes, he is.
Miss Penny come to see about Ida and her new baby, too.
Aunt Mattie's kinda got old-fashioned ideas.
Thinks mommas can't eat things like meat and greens.
Miss Penny said mommas can eat anything after the babies come that didn't hurt them before the baby come,
and they feel better for it, too.
Baby's cord doin' okay.
Most of my patients have learned by now, you don't put on anything but a sterile dressing.
No grease, no powder.
[Aunt Mattie delivers a plate of food to Ida.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Miss Penny and Miss Mary go about their work; Ida and her daughter eat.]
[Women are shown in a waiting area, one holding her infant.]
[Miss Mary:] When Ida come for her six weeks' check-up, Maybell was there, too.
Poor girl, I felt right sorry for her.
Ida just kept bragging about that youngun and all the time Maybell just kept looking and thinking about hers.
Dr. Newton always checks our mothers to make sure that they didn't have no tears and that their wombs is all right.
The doctor said Maybell's coming along just fine and look like she's been eating better, too.
Still Dr. Newton knowed something else had been troubling Maybell this time,
but Lord, that girl had no call to fret herself.
'Cause in four months' time her Adam Junior
had growed out to be as pretty a baby as you ever saw.
[A healthy baby Adam is shown, and Maybell looks down at him, smiling.]
[Chorus singing.]
[Father Adam is having a photograph taken of himself and baby Adam.]
[Laughter]
[Miss Mary:] Well, I'm going to hang my picture of Maybell's baby right up here on the top.
[Ida:] I bet you're proud of that bitty baby, Miss Mary.
[Miss Mary:] Why, Ida, I'm proud of all my babies.
[Chorus singing.]